early leads in Paris investigators have
recovered two cars this VW Polo was
found near the Bataclan concert hall
while in the eastern suburb of Mantua
investigators recovered a second a siut
police also found Kalashnikov rifles in
the car and are connecting it to the
attacks on people sitting outside
restaurants in the 10th and 11th are on
these moles meanwhile in Brussels the
Belgian news agency quotes prosecution
sources saying two of the gunmen were
French citizens who lived in the Belgian
capital police there have taken a total
of seven persons into custody at least
one of the suspects is thought to have
been in Paris over the weekend the VW
car found in Paris has Belgian number
plates parking tickets led investigators
to the brussels suburb of molenbeek an
area well-known in terrorism probes
thought back in Paris some parts of the
puzzle are slowly becoming clearer
french prosecutors have named one of the
attackers as 29 year old oh ma is male
lost if I he caught police's attention
due to the violation of public power
from 2004 to 2010 he was pronounced
guilty for eight times but has never
been in prison also he was blacklisted
by the police due to extreme behaviors
boy IDK lisa hugh bond over the south of
paris police here have taken most afire
and father into custody for questioning
as confirmation emerges that most if i
was indeed a French citizen